HELLO! Konichiwa minna-san! (Hello everyone)
It's me
Peeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee-
[Gags (ew)]
Welcome back to another video!
Now, I wanted to make this video before
But I wasn't sure if it was a good idea, but then
I made a lil bit of a video like this in another video
WHAT THE HELL AM I TALKING ABOUT?
We're gonna travel all across the world.
From Tokyo, to....
back to Sweden!
Let's go!
[Batman transition]
In case this wasn't obvious,
Or, for some reason you didn't know, my core value.
I am Swedish.
[Epic choir] That's right- that's why I'm so goddamn attractive-
And so... Goddamn...
What's a bad Swedish trait?
Cucked. [Chuckles]
So I grew up in Gothenburg
It's the second largest city of SwEden!
On the west coast, which means we get all the delicious fish,
Which is why I like fish so much!
Cause we get the good fish
Over here in Stockholm? BAD FISH.
Over here in Gothenburg? VERY GOOD FISH.
I tell you about fish? You wanted me to tell you more about fish?
[Accent intensifies] I am becoming extremely Swedish! [Laughs]
I think that the thing is here, is that I have not been back in Gothenburg, for...
I don't know! Like eight years? Since I went on this YouTube journey,
I have not been back to Gothenburg! It's really strange.
The fuck is that on the road? Someone's bike helmet-
Where should we go first? Oh, I think I know now.
I think I grew up like at the top of one of these buildings.
I don't remember anything from it
So I don't even know why I'm bringing it up.
All I can remember from this time is that I sucked on [my] pacifier for way too long-
[Laughs]
Good times! Good Memories!
When I was a kid I had this really weird tic, like- for me to sleep
I would suck my- not my thumb, like normal people, I would suck on my finger
And wiggle my hair? [Laughs]
But the weird part about it was that I thought it was so great
that I wanted other people to know how great it was
I remember- I remember telling other people like-
No, listen- what you need to do is you need to suck your finger and wiggle your hair back-
It's- its the greatest thing ever! Okay-
[Laughs] You're missing out! You don't understand!
Maybe there's a weird gay undertone here that..
I was not intending for.
Okay uh- Ah yes, this f**king road. I would walk home every day from school
It's so goddamn long
These are really pretty houses
I remember my mom, didn't want me to go to like,
one of the local schools? She wanted me to go to a really good school
in the center, so I had to
go home from school pretty far, I remember it was REALLY far
but my mom got me and my sister a cellphone
when we were like, 5 years old or something like that?
Which Back in the day when we had those giant brick phones? Just in case something happen
but I did had to travel pretty far to go home from school
and walk up here, but I remember it was also
kind of weird cause uh- when you're in school in the center like
a far, far away school you don't really get
that many friends in your own neighbourhood, uh
classmates just live all across Gothenburg and I remember [laughs]
there was one point when my parents were like-
"it's Saturday, why don't you go out with friends" but I'm like- "all my friends are super far away"
and they were like "tshh just go out" and i'm like- "I DON'T HAVE ANY FRIENDS DAD
WHAT DO YOU WANT ME TO SAY"- it sounds more sad than it is
but I remember there was a time in my life when I was like "I actually don't have any friends"
[LAUGHS]
is ANYONE SUPRISED? and it was so shameful like
I didn't tell my parents but like- I- IN RETROSPECTIVE
it makes total sense like-
I- this is a thing I understand later cause it was
so shocking to me, this revelation like- "I don't have any friends at all"
but I wish this was in the last video. This is the house I grew up in
This is the school I went to
it's called [something in swedish] it's where all the privileged
kids went to school and I really appreciate my mom putting me in a
really good school. Namaste mom. Even tho it did come
with a price of not having any friends- umm
I can't really see anything I don't know why I wanna look into the school
like some goddamn creep but I don't remember much
except one time there was a legendary snowball fight
between two schools over here cause all
the kids from this other school- they came over and
we had a legendary snowball fight over this fence [laughs]
LEGENDARY. It was like the battle
of Normandy, basically. I remember
we also used to call like- all the kids, all the other kids
like "intruders" and we had to have
this big meeting about not calling eachother intruders
very swedish, very nice [laughs]
I also remember someone pulling the fire alarm and we had to have a meeting too
and then the principal- we were like
it's four hundred people in the room and the principal stands up and
be like "can the one that pulled the fire alarm
PLEEEASE come forward"- and like, OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE NOT
GONNA DO THAT in front of four hundred people like "yeah it was me,
I'm sorry"- it wasn't me by the way okay,
IT WASN'T ME. There was also uh-
I don't know for some reason this is where we entered the school
and there was like a lady that you HAD to say hi to
I don't know why-  is that a swedish thing? I can't tell
She was nice. Don't get me wrong. Oh my God
they still have these squares [laughs]
I can't believe they still have these squares, God bless
those squares were the best game ever, I don't know if you guys
had these in school, but you had a basket ball
and we called it king but it probably has some other name for you
but basically, there was a king in one square
and then there was a queen and then there
were these two pawns
and you started off as a pawn- and then
if someone obviously gets out of the game you move up
until you become the king, so basically the way you play
was that- the one that was king could make up the rules
of the game.[Laughs] So as soon as you become King
You're like "OK, the rules are X, Y, Z" like-
and you can just make up any rules whatsoever, which was idk
thats was just to made it fun. you could be like "ok I-
you lose if the ball bounces in your court" and then you just go *BLaAaA!* [Laughs]
And then a lot of times, what you would do is that you would come up
with a pack, with a queen so you would just work together to
eliminate everyone else, so no one else could beat you
which led to a lot of scumbaggery. I remembered like a lot
of bullying where you'd just target- I wasn't a bully ok
But we would target just like specific people and be like
"oh yeah, this person can't play" idk [giggles]
people get so upset of this ba- game, I remember the
people are leaving, going outside the school which wasn't allowed
just 'cause they get so mad over playing this game.
Ah, So it makes me really happy the people still have these
Godawful game
I hope that's what they are still playing.
(chuckles)
Good times, good memories.
Ahhh oh god, heres
Football court.
One thing you need to note 'bout Sweden is that
We are not good very at football but we still love football
Okay. I remember every goddamn gym class
People always wanted to play football
And our gym teacher was like "I didn't like playing football"
And my gym teacher would always go "Aye"
"Who wants to play football this game", "who wants to play foot this (unheard)"
And everyone was like "Yeah, me, me, me".
And me in the back, "Yeah me, let's play football"
I hated gym class just because we always play football
Any other game, i am totally fine with
But it was ALWAYS football
But I wasn't good at football, i don't like playing football.
I HATE FOOTBALL!!
I STILL HATE FOOTBALL!
Listen
People you know the classic "Oh pick you and pick you and blah blah"
You get picked last.
The thing is, what's worse than being picked last is being picked
Out of the assumption that you're actually good at football
Okay? Everyone was like
"oH i wAs aLwAys PiCkeD lAsT iN"
"foOtBaLL WhaTever"
Whatever okay? Boohoho I don't have time for you.
But what's even worse is when people pick you EARLY.
like...
I remember I was sometimes, like, the second pick
and then people would just realize
I actually suck at football.
**brEATHES**
And then they would reinforce this thing that I already know,
"HEY! You really suck at football."
I fucking know!
AND THEN YOU'RE PICKED LAST.
HUH?
HOW DO YOU THINK *THAT* FEELS?!
It doesn't feel good D:
i hAtE fOoTbALL!!! *rage*
[Laughter]
...stupid football. Ruined my life...
Great times.
I have... fantastic memories.
uh, from this school.
It was great, I loved it.
I really, really, loved it.
Then when you're innnnnnn...
7th grade,
you go to this school
which is the same school.
This is a loooot bigger.
Uhhh,
I remember how massive and overwhelming this school felt like
when you first started at it.
THEY BETTER NOT BE PLAYING FOOTBALL
If you play brännboll--
I was reeeaaaallly good at brännboll, 'kay?
But no one [unintelligible]
Stupid--
**s t u p i d  s p o r t s .**
[Mutters to self]
If you are from Gothenberg,
People as well,  cause it didn't really bother me
to be alone as well
UuuUuM at all I remember people pointing out
like why are you walking alone and stuff like that - I'm like I don't know
I don't care based on that I assume
people probably thought I was pretty weird BUT I did have good grades
still....the thing is like I went to this really
REALLY nice school where everyone is generally
very nice uh to each other
the last three years of school you need  high grades
to get into the uh to keep going in the school
and I didn't have good grades  and then we looked at other schools
we had like a day where we got to visit others schools
and I just saw how awful they were and I'm like  FULL PANIC mode
like I need good grades because I don't wanna to go to a normal school
with-with normal kids ..which I don't know
if that was good or bad but YEAH but I got into it.
Then I uh got into university I went to ....(some school of tech)
where is it? There it is! Good Ol' (Chalmers?)
out of ther -  like - bler- for- forks in my life
I think this is the strangest one
to look back on
I think my life could have
completely different road depending on
like small decisions like very small decisions
would have made a massive significance I think in my life
which is kinda scary looking back on
when I applied for (school)
I actually wanted to study architecture or maybe I think theres a course called
art design or something like that
like it be more creative ahhh
but still logical type of professions or
educations and I think that really suits me
cause I think thats who I work but I never thought I would get in
because I think you need like uhhh one of the highest averages
basically I just I didn't think I would get in
so I just applied to the same course that my parents
went to which was a lil easier to get into
but still really hard and a really really good course
but the thing was that I got way better grades than I thought
and I actually would have gotten into my
what I actually preferred to go to but the thing  was
I didn't apply to it as my uuhhh first choice
cause I was like I should probably just go here I won't get into the other ones
Anyway and I just kinda went with it  I didn't really question it
and the thing was like what happen then was
course (in school) that
I didn't really want to go to which just lead
to eventually just hating it I couldn't relate
to my classmates I felt like even more
more solitude than I was in
Highschool I just felt like a total outcast I couldn't
just day 1 it was just really hard
at this time was as well since I got into this school
my parents we so proud of me that they let me stay in my own apartment
as well I still had to pay rent for it but
I had an apartment at the bottom floor in here
And I would walk to university just absolutely dreading it just awful
about going it was definitely I think this
the probably the worst part of my life I got into the school
but I hated it and if I had
quit then I would basically have nothing going for me
so it was - it was like not even an option
but it also felt - like ah - is this what my life is gonna be
Im just gonna have to be around people that you know
we nice people - don't get me wrong but t
asd english is good